[Musique]
la seule fois où j'ai eu une remarque
antisémite
et ça c'est la première remarque mais je
n'en ai jamais eu d'autre au lycée quand
j'étais au jardin de l'enfant parce que
c'est à l'époque on entrait il y avait
un essai de fille et où les garçons
étaient accueillis jusqu'en 7ème
commissaire y allaient
m'emmenait le matin j'allais au jardin
d'enfant à quatre ans quelque chose
comme ça 5 ans il y avait la cour des
petits et je revois toujours une
camarade
et qui me dit ta mère est juive tu es
juive ta mère mon grand en fait brûler
en enfer et je suis rentré en pleurs à
la maison naturellement
ça doit être probablement à peu près mon
plus vieux souvenir d'enfant
[Musique]
Simone Veil
seul l'espoir apaise la douleur
[Musique]
un podcast original produit par Lina
écrit par les avenstein avec le concours
de Dominique Missika
[Musique]
11 mai 2006 Bry-sur-Marne
Simone Veil 78 ans arrive dans le studio
de Lina d'ailleurs mauve chignon brun
elle prend place sans perdre de temps et
fixe la caméra d'un regard vif
elle est la 101ème ancienne déportée à
participer à la collecte de témoignages
conçus par Lina et la Fondation pour la
mémoire de la Shoah dont elle est la
présidente mais ce jour-là ni présidente
ni ancienne ministre ni femme publique
Simone Veil témoigne pour l'histoire
répondant aux questions de Catherine
Bernstein elle se confie sans détour et
déploie patiemment tous les fils de sa
vie
l'enfance l'éruption de la guerre
l'enfer des camps puis le difficile
retour ce que vous allez entendre est un
témoignage inédit c'est un récit intense
en quatre épisodes qui suit l'implacable
chronologie de la déportation des Juifs
de France
Simone Veil raconte tout elle ne veut
rien éditer
sa mémoire est précise et sa colère
intacte seul c'est silence que nous
avons conservé viendra rappeler qu'une
part de cette histoire est restée là-bas
dans ce lieu dont elle n'est jamais
vraiment sorti
[Musique]
Simone Veil seul l'espoir apaise la
douleur
première épisode de l'arrestation à la
déportation
[Musique]
Nice 30 mars 1944 la guerre dure depuis
4 ans Simone Veil à 16 ans sous le faux
nom de Simone Jacquier elle vit caché
chez l'une des professeurs de son lycée
elle vient de passer son bac et surfer
la fin des épreuves lorsqu'elle est
appréhendée dans la rue par des agents
de la Gestapo
[Musique]
je vais arrêter dans la rue à Nice dans
le quartier qui était d'ailleurs
l'ancien quartier aux habitations le
quartier des Musiciens et assez près
d'ailleurs de l'hôtel Excelsior qui
était l'hôtel où il mettait les gens
avant d'être dans l'hôtel avant
pas très loin de la gare
SNCF
des deux personnes je crois une femme et
un homme qui me demande mes papiers
j'étais avec un camarade de camarade et
qui m'ont demandé mes papiers les
sorties
n'imaginant pas qu'il y avait un risque
et
ils nous ont amené tous les trois à
l'hôtel de la Gestapo qui n'était pas
loin à pied et ils m'ont dit vous avez
un faux papiers etc mais non ils m'ont
montré toutes ces cartes alors je me
suis dit il faut que je fasse prévenir
qu'ils changent de carte d'identité et
je pense qu'ils ont suivi le garçon qui
a fait ça et j'ai donné
en me disant qu'il y avait
aucun risque que la famille soit et par
hasard vraiment
effroyable
ils sont tombés dans l'escalier enfin
ils ont rencontré les gens qui étaient
là
et en plus ce même mon frère qui n'était
pas si circoncis et qui était là qui
n'était ni moment ni mon frère n'était
jamais venu ce qui fait que le soir
était à peu près quelques heures
d'intervalles votre sœur Madeleine
votre maman et mon frère et vous vous
retrouvez tous les quatre à l'exception
et on se retrouve tous les quatre avec
une petite semaine ou une semaine
on restait en général une semaine enfin
on restait pas une semaine c'est à dire
tu dois me prendre le jour auquel on
était arrêté dans la semaine puisque
c'était en fin de semaine je crois que
ça va être le samedi qu'il y avait un
wagon qui était réservé à wagon lasse
les gens qui étaient en wagon agradéaire
où là il faisait aussi
une espèce de chantage en disant s'il y
en a un qui s'évade les autres dans le
même compartiment se Frontier en fait si
on avait imaginé ce que c'était on a
dans l'hôtel chaque jour il ramène
soit des gens qui ont été arrêtés chez
eux soit des gens qui ont à Nice ils ont
beaucoup fait ça d'arrêter dans dans la
rue sans sans grande rafle comme ça au
hasard
dans l'hôtel vous êtes dans une chambre
juste tous les quatre où il y a d'autres
qui sont les conditions de fête tous les
cas comme c'était des chambres d'hôtel
peut-être qu'il y avait une ou deux
personnes je sais pas on était par terre
sur des matelas on était
convenablement nourri et avec
ce curieusement les SS qui étaient là il
y en avait un qui était en alsacien et
qui était très gentil
est-ce qu'on l'a pas de fait faire une
commission pas je crois pas en inquiétez
très très malheureux d'être là
d'ailleurs très souvent les Alsaciens
ont été dans les SS et à ce moment-là
dès le lendemain on est incité je serai
pas autorisé mais incité à écrire pour
demander faire envoyer ce dont nous
avons besoin et maman écrit à son ami
italienne puisque c'est une italienne
non seulement
catholique mais en plus de famille très
très convenable au point de vue de
Marie et médecin et elle s'est
elle sait où trouver soit par Antoinette
soit par un chiffre d'affaires
grand chose enfin des vêtements des
vêtements chauds couverture ou ce que
peut les Allemands nous inciter à
demander le maximum de choses puisque
toute façon c'était décidé à être
récupéré
et là donc reste ne sont pas arrêtés
votre père et votre grand-mère qui eux
sont qui sont ensemble ils sont dans
l'ensemble chez justement chez les
boletti ils sont deux frères qui avaient
tous les deux étaient d'ailleurs à des
moments différents successivement
dessinateurs chez nous on va chez mon
père et qui
vraiment ce sont des gens
qui est vraiment pas grand logement et
qui garderont ma grand-mère
jusqu'à la Libération
à la Libération maison que les temps
entre de Suisse la libération la France
ils ont la chercher à Nice et
à Paris mais jusque-là elle reste
à peu près une semaine à l'hôtel
Excelsior avant
oui ou 400 jours je suis je sais plus
quel jour on a choisi c'était je crois
que les trains il y avait un train une
fois par semaine enfin il remplissait un
wagon une fois par semaine il leur
fallait leur wagon une fois par semaine
mais je ne sais plus peut-être 4-5 jours
seulement ça pas été on n'est pas assez
très longtemps
des souvenirs ce voyage entre Nice et
Drancy
c'était un voyage relativement
confortable puisque c'était un wagon qui
était à wagon ordinaire raccroché à
notre ordinaire alors simplement aux
deux bouts de trucs c'était gardé par
les SS puis la consigne de dire si avec
soi-disant un responsable par
compartiment pour le cas où il y aurait
une évasion et puis les sentinelles qui
font pendant le trajet ici aller au bout
pendant dans les arrêts de garde
puisqu'il y a les arrêts ordinaires le
résultat font les sentinelles mais où
toute façon personne
quand déjà c'est un jeune a une vérité
de s'évader les eaux disent mais alors
on va tous être voilà
alors que probablement la garde était
pas tellement serrée et que certains
aurait pu se mettre mais
ça a été vraiment pour les gens qui sont
partis en wagon alors bien sûr
certainement plus difficile enfin les
gens auraient eu aussi le chantage fait
sur les autres et toujours un chantage
je voudrais
très lourd je sais pas est-ce qu'on
parlait déjà Drancy oui je pense que oui
mais on pense pas beaucoup plus loin
dans si aussi on va aller travailler
dans des camps etc on imagine pas
mais même dans les wagons ensuite même
quand on est à Drancy
[Musique]
vous arrivez à Drancy d'après mes notes
le 7 avril 44
vous vous rappelez des premières
impressions que vous avez eu
si grande pièce c'est sinistre c'est bon
on reste ensemble
le plus possible on n'a pas travaillé du
tout on n'a pas été affecté un quel
qu'on travaille parce que on savait
qu'on était destiné à partir très vite
la seule question qui se pose c'est très
vite on apprend que les jeunes gens
ne partent pas et on dit que enfin les
chefs du camp
ils vont rester en France pour
travailler pour l'organisation toute
alors comme on n'est pas du tout sur de
ce qui se passe après dans 6 pour nous
on essaye pas du tout de dire à notre
frère au contraire on dit si on a un qui
reste si vous devez rester en France si
les hommes doivent rester en France il
vaut mieux rester et donc il reste à
Drancy
enfin du moins ça se décide la veille
c'est la veille au moment où les gens
qui partent dans le combat le lendemain
matin tôt sont avertis ils disent que
les jeunes gens enfin les hommes de
moins de 50 ans et les jeunes gens les
jeunes gens à partir de 18 ans
c'est comme ça que mon frère reste
seulement si il n'est pas déporté
à Auschwitz et quant aux autres
quand on part
on sait on dit on va travailler
est-ce qu'on va travailler en Allemagne
enfin on sait pas où mais très
certainement
on peut penser
que
parmi les responsables
juifs du camp certains doivent se douter
de ce qui se passe on dit on va petit
spoil voilà on sait pas alors est-ce que
c'est l'Allemagne est-ce que c'est la
France est-ce que c'est la Pologne
est-ce que c'est
mais d'abord on pense qu'on va rester en
famille pense pas qu'il y aura une
séparation
personne à ce moment-là
que la chambre de chambre à gaz une
chose comme ça vraiment personne
alors on se dit il y en a bon ce sera
dur on travaillera on rentrera on
rentrera pas pour les enfants
on imagine pas
vous partez avec le convoi 71 le 13
avril 44
parmi
1480 personnes donc d'ailleurs j'ai vu
plusieurs enfants des enfants des yeux
vous êtes dans le même wagon que votre
mère et votre sœur
toutes les trois et toutes tout à fait
ensemble enfin oui on est toujours
restés
toujours n'a jamais été séparé je dirais
que la première fois la seule fois
où nous avons été séparés
parce que même à un moment assez
longtemps j'ai travaillé à l'extérieur
bergenbergen à l'extérieur de
des camps un peu séparés il fallait
passer les barbelés des contrôles si
vous avez regardé Melsen mais je
rentrais toujours le soir voilà journée
finie je rentrais et la seule fois où je
ne suis pas rentré je crois peut-être
deux autres fois parce qu'on avait
travaillé jusqu'à minuit à la cuisine à
cause des bombardements enfin on
n'aurait pas pu rentrer mais sans ça la
seule fois où je ne suis pas rentré voir
ma sœur c'est le journal Libération par
exemple sans ça on est toujours resté
moi toujours été ensemble dans les
convois on a
et quels sont les souvenirs qui vous
reste ce transport de ce voyage
la place c'est la place pour s'asseoir
et pour essayer de dormir peut-être ce
plus que bon puis après les tunnels il y
a ce qu'il faut manger ce qu'on a ou
est-ce qu'il faut en garder qu'est-ce
qu'on aura ensuite parce que quand on
part on a tout de même on part avec du
pain je sais pas ce monde de choses et
on se dit qu'est-ce qu'on aura là-bas
est-ce que alors il y a les théories de
ceux qui mangent tout en disant c'est
toujours ça ceux qui veulent garder
enfin bon d'essayer de voir où on
s'arrête par la petite lucarne toute
petite donc de se rendre compte assez
rapidement enfin dès qu'on est sorti de
France qu'on traverse
l'Allemagne à ce moment-là au mois
d'avril je dirais qu'il fait ni froid
enfin auprès de mes températures
mais des gens qui sont malades des gens
des qui pleure
[Musique]
et que nous on essaye
de se tenir ensemble dans un coin
je sais pas beaucoup de souvenirs
[Musique]
Simone Veil
seul l'espoir apaise la douleur
un podcast original en quatre épisodes
produit par Lina
réalisée par mexom noise écrit par les
avenstein avec le concours de Dominique
Missika
[Musique]
avec la voix 10 adorada musique
originale Michael yo
[Musique]
ce podcast a été réalisé à partir du
témoignage de Simone Veil recueilli par
Catherine Bernstein le 9 mai 2006 dans
le cadre de mémoire de la Shoah une
initiative de la Fondation pour la
mémoire de la Shoah et de Lina
[Musique]
l'intégralité du récit de Simone Veil
est disponible en librairie dans seul
l'espoir apaise la douleur une coalition
Flammarion INA et en vidéo sur le site
des grands entretiens de Lina entretien
au pluriel point inna.fr